google l'a précédemment humiliait né à
exploser sur les goûts il revient
aujourd'hui plus fort que jamais google
n'a cru te kiffe rohff annonce a fait
mardi à rabat ok le tout monde s'excuse
aujourd'hui d'accord aujourd'hui se
trouvent sur zone le ghana der vaart
souvenez vous on devait deviner les
recherches les plus fréquentes sur
google on a été des élans le maire
d'aujourd'hui on doit juste deviner quel
thème intéresse que ces gens tout autre
là ça a résumé de merde comme un [ __ ]
de chaque fois peter kay à 74 mille
roches est mensuel voilà burberry en a
plus bas tard aux oies pas se laisser
faire mon pote miley cyrus comme il y en
a plus d'un million cinq cent mille bien
sûr que oui le changement climatique
en at il plus ou moins passé hyper
triste mais je suis sûr qu'il en a moins
[ __ ] british airways saa plus à mon
avis que 246 mines plus tard mais
l'ironie l'ironie changement climatique
240 vide il plus tard deux compagnies
l'avions fait 3 millions est-ce qu'il ya
plus de trois millions trois pour des
dyson ouais mais bon on est bon plus
tard ça vous voyez ça c'est l'esprit de
vendanges c'est l'esprit de compétition
justin timberlake et en a plus c'est sûr
ou alors tu dis quoi tu sois google 1 tu
veux je te rendre visite la rue de
londres à paris tu crois que c'est
pourri tu habites ils vont envoyer des
vétérans pour me tuer je ferai plus
jamais de page d'accueil sur youtube
c'est fini truman show est ce que ça a
pu ce que je dis molex non voilà on est
bien jim carrey un peu plus oui on a
tout le monde en y performent
l'homophobie un chef de montfort je
pense qu'il a fait plus je suis une
merde je suis une merde non c'est fini
tu trouves une fois tu es mort va faire
mal c'est qu'on va faire bien mieux vaut
faire bien mieux faire bien mieux
loneliness game of thrones les stanley
kubrick moi c'est sûr guinness mois au
tête à ce que 100 milles d'écart à ses
formats aux caisses exposition à la
tuque jury je me dis m adel face à des
pulsions sexuelles c'est un peu chelou
et s'il ya plus de gens qui veulent
écouter les chansons datent elles ou
est-ce qu'il ya plus de gens qui veulent
savoir comment faire l'amour bizarrement
car il faudrait pas à moi converse mois
de nicki minaj ou [ __ ] c'était quand
même beaucoup
wikileaks est une organisation de gauche
a fondé par julian un objectif de publie
des documents s'exerce politique sociale
à l'échelle du monde
rwe les gens préfèrent acheter des
converse oh là là quelle théorie de
folie alors google vous à tous et wave
ou racisme bien plus que son 105 milles
[ __ ] bien plus attention online poker
bas plus la masure qui joua sight
tu vois google je sais que tu as
compotée sur ce coup là ne ment pas les
assassins ils vont passer par cette
porte pour matin tu sais avec quoi je
vais les attendre bâtard reggae ps pay
pal ont beaucoup de gens me secouer cap
hape ashton friends c'est culte de ouf
mais ces vieux os quand même plus oui
allez samsung galaxy ace 6 bien plus oui
perdre du poids oh [ __ ] ça c'est ça
pue tellement de gens plus que c'est
mignon un [ __ ] ouais d'accord je me
suis tellement mulliez google n'a même
plus besoin d'envoyer un assassin la
faisait fi nit nachat voilà là on
atteint truc
misys non au [ __ ] pas mal quand même
sound of anarchy c'est une série de
sendou c'est sûr voilà du lave-auto jim
carrey - hélas lui est faux acciona re
max tellement dur parano non non mais se
tromper j'ai remis un fatum toi mon cher
barack obama mais il faudrait que je
fasse un score d'au moins 40
e-cigarettes 1 ça alors ça tu crois je
regarde ton petit jeu google ah ça c'est
moi dans dix minutes ça continue iphone
si c'est ce bon alors là
bon alors là de lord of the rings à
moins que de filles je pense quand même
- ouais beaucoup moins après entre la
nourriture des années un iphone je
prends la nuance hiriart à mon avis y en
a beaucoup
ouais on n'est pas largement pink floyd
acda physique et en plus c'est culte ou
même soupe à eau
c'est pareil il a voulu me piéger c'est
ça cinq stars aux thèses au soudan la
mort
david fincher s'est quand même bien
stylet il fait des [ __ ] de film good
girl tout ça allait plus pokémon alors
là oui yorkshire terrier bas - mais non
mais t'es sérieux ce truc là vous
intéresse y voit plus que de la bouffe
ya un problème dans votre tête
j'avoue je suis juste frustré parce que
j'ai perdu jeremy clarkson battu fait
pas plus que j'aurais support je suis
désolé enfin pas mal quand même hein
mais le féminisme
ça fait plus que ça ou pas je sais pas
s'il tape ce mot-là directement dans ce
fait moins je pense ouais ok but de why
there c'est la bière calmez vous [ __ ]
c'était paraît olala des cours de
conduite est ce que ça fait plus que 2
que de la bière banon en bois labert
puisqu'on ne veut des leçons conduit à
la vôtre à netflix alors là alors la
perte de poids on a eu dix plus ça
alors je veux qu'au cours des quatre
prochaines années ce chiffre sera
multiplié par cent mille chez name no
name l'aîné des modems fac hier c'est
plus que le mi5
oui et cannabis c'est plus que la bière
oui cocaïne
c'est moins que le key biscayne où apple
c'est plus mark zuckerberg c'est moi tu
es triste c'est moins bornes alors là
alors là ça y va
voilà à pour consommer des deux tu as lu
bond à des gens tapent mois pour voter
que tout hacking quand même ce google
c'est bien sans qu'on ne pas retrouver
exit auquel on n'embauche pas non
maintenant on est à la moitié de faire
un score non embauche - fespam safem
plus le sucre ou non c'est bon c'est bon
c'est pas con c'était fait exprès il ya
plus de gens qui tapent liposuccion que
john quitte à bretelles de luxe hyatt
c'est la même personne qui tablent ainsi
non une fois tu fais taper ça par
curiosité hop c'est un nom qui en a dix
mecs on a dix on a dit ça t'a son google
est ce que c'est la défaite pour vous ok
ok 12 bs4 au ppt
kristen stewart est ce qu'elle fait plus
un [ __ ] mais n'a pas plu ce mec tu
tapes jamais kristen stewart je tape
twillight voir twilight
du coup on s'en fout il ya deux millions
sept cent mille personnes qui veulent
voir la vie de 7,9 sur google chaque
mois [ __ ]
j'en peux plus tôt mais ça fait une
heure ça fait une halte à tout va son
brushing son truc et je suis un rageux
et sa voix ya cette idée n'était pas
d'aimer ça lui a plu moi je m'y tiendrai
google fait attention vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri je me pointe rues de londres avec
mon pistolet quand même le bruit est nul
ça fait peur à personne